tout est arrivé très vite
une éruption solaire
adieu récolte ces nourritures un dieu
tout
alors je me suis caché
terrifié et tellement seul
et puis j'ai trouvé
bon qu'est-ce qu'on commande s'il te
plaît enlève qui quitte la table enlève
t'écoute de la tête voilée à toi
tu vois je suis en train de travailler
sur un truc intéressant sorte d'acte de
foi j'ai
si tu peux parler dis moi quelque chose
qui te concerne au bo doit protéger
tiens
si on n'ose pas avant que la tempête
éclate on aura tous dès que tu sais
marcher on s'en bat 1 2
ça c'est tombé
[Musique]
droit vers l'ouest à travers les
montagnes tu aimerais tu que je conduis
ne braque pas trop c'est trop gros qui
soulève le pied les bleus un poil
parfait
[Musique]
cette fois debout quand j'apprends à
part les chiens
je ne crois pas qu'il m'aime
mary poppins cas
cette fois quelque chose
[Musique]
devrait être en sécurité quand on sera
dans les montagnes les choses terribles
bonsecours du miel une température de 65
degrés
un rayonnement ultraviolet
et des êtres humains qui se cachent dans
l'emploi
c'est quoi qu'on n'y arrivera pas sans
mon équipe ce qu'on fait on le fait
ensemble
je crois en toi fils
[Musique]